Did you get the closed interval from negative 1 to 1? If so, you should be very
proud of yourself. I know I am. Let's see how we got that solution. Remember
when you're working with a compound inequality that's written in this form, we
can perform operations as long as we do the same operation, to all three
portions of the quation. The first thing I want to do is to get rid of this
fraction by multiplying through by the least common denominator, and the least
common denominator is 2. When I multiply 2 by negative 3, I get negative 6. When
I multiply 2 by 5 x minus 1 over 2, I'm simply left with 5 x minus 1, and when I
multiply 2 times 2, I get 4. Next I'm going to add 1 to each part of the
equation so I can isolate the variable in the middle. When I do that, negative 6
plus 1 is negative 5, and 4 plus 1 is positive 5. Now I can divide through by 5.
Negative 5 divided by 5 is negative 1, less than or equal to x, less than or
equal to 5 over 5 is positive 1. Let's draw that on the number line. This
portion of the inequality says that negative 1 is less than or equal to x, which
is the same as x is greater than or equal to negative 1. So, that means we're
going to be going in that direction.
This portion of the equation says x is less than or equal to positive 1, so we
use a square bracket and the answer's going here. So we have the interval from
negative 1 to 1 using the square brackets.